[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
the 2020 presidential race is
effectively underway and has been since
the midterms in november
the most formidable candidates have not
officially announced yet
they want to be fashionably late to the
party but it's obvious who they are
their shadow campaigns are busy lining
up donors ginning up publicity and
trying in general to seem impressive
the most vigorous contender in this
group is robert
bateau o'rourke of texas o'rourke nearly
beat ted cruz in a senate race this fall
you'll remember
democrats love him for that affluent
progressives on the coast
love him best he's one of them in the
betting markets o'rourke is now the
favorite to win the democratic
nomination two years from now he
plausibly could be sitting in the oval
office
so it's worth taking beto o'rourke
seriously
what kind of president would he be at
this point we can only guess we do know
that like most people in his social
class
he is totally against border walls
we'll fight when necessary against a
president
who's focused on building walls no wall
is going to solve legitimate security
concerns then perhaps you can be
forgiven for thinking that a wall
is going to solve a problem we in el
paso are ashamed of this now
but this is going to be one of those
moments where the folks
in germany look back on the berlin wall
or the united states looks back on its
uh project to intern japanese americans
during
world war ii did you hear that
so berlin wall bad border wall
also bad indeed bad very much like in
turning the japanese during world war
ii was bad it was another racist attack
on asians from the fdr administration
or something like that whatever walls
are bad okay
so far that's been about the sum total
of what we know about beto o'rourke's
policy views that and he also went to
the dentist recently we know because he
put it on instagram
but thankfully now we know even more
o'rourke just did a two-hour long
interview with a reporter from jeff
bezos's washington newspaper the
washington post
which like o'rourke himself is a
full-time mouthpiece for guilty rich
people
o'rourke knew he was speaking to his own
community so he relaxed long enough to
explain what he really thinks about
things
including border walls walls are bad
o'rourke explained not just because they
in turn perfectly decent japanese people
but because they literally commit murder
or rather
we commit murder when we build walls as
o'rourke put it
if you construct a barrier along our
southern border quote
you will ensure death you and i
as americans have caused the deaths
of others through these walls and quote
let that settle
whoa we killed people and we didn't even
know it that's pretty heavy how many
people did we kill
should we turn ourselves into the
authorities or prepare for life on the
lamb
do we need new passports cosmetic
surgery does paraguay have an
extradition treaty
so many questions the real question
though is
what the hell is beta o'rourke talking
about
to be fair it's not like he's pretending
to know aurora makes it perfectly clear
that
he has no idea what he's saying and
that's okay he's not embarrassed about
it
when the washington post asked o'rourke
what he would do about illegal aliens
overstaying their visas which is a huge
part of our immigration crisis
he answered this way quote i don't know
thank you mr spicoli please take your
seat beto's not into details
vedo's into ideas big ideas
ideas of the future sweeping panoramic
truths about being
in personhood and new modes of authentic
expression
the kind of stuff that would spill your
bong water and blow
your mind beto is not a micro guy he's
bigger than that
he's a transformer and what beta wants
to transform next after failing to
transform texas
is nothing less than the united states
of america starting with the beliefs
this country was founded on
that's what he told jeff bezos's
newspaper does this still work he asked
this being america and beta wasn't so
sure
and so he asked the question that future
historians will recognize as a pivot
point in the life of this country can
america
quote still be managed by the same
principles that were set down
230 plus years ago and that's not a
small question
the principles beto refers to would
include the bill of rights freedom of
speech
freedom of religion and assembly the
right to self-defense
and a fair trial does any of that still
matter
are those all just old ideas stumbling
blocks that are preventing people like
beto
good and brilliant people who went to
colombia and have beautiful weekend
homes
from getting the power they need to turn
this place into a
truly awesome country a country where
skateboards outnumber suvs and everyone
is
thin and has quality child care a nation
that values hot yoga above football
a place where insensitive thoughts are
banned and punished appropriately
plato doesn't know the answer to those
questions right now but he's thinking
about it